Sark is he the second Oh Junior you can
break your old man's heart if I have to
I would have to break anything clearly
you've never made an omelet he beat me
by one second
ah funny mrs. duck it's what's
comfortable like old times
this is never my wife you two can still
walk away from me
no we will I know you've suffered ah let
the Captain America God's righteous man
pretending you could live without a war
I can't physically throw up in my mouth
if you believe in peace and let us keep
it I think you're confusing peace with
quiet yeah what's the vibranium for I'm
glad you asked that because I wanted to
take this time to explain my evil plan
[Music]
which one all of them
[Music]
[Music]
stay down keep these limp-wristed mine
in the games guys is this a code GREEN
boy static the girl tried to warp my
mind take special care I got a human to
keep her faith fortunately I have my tea
this is going
I've done the whole mind control thing
not a fan of the vibranium is getting
away and you're not going anywhere of
course not I'm already there you'll get
John look first you might need to hedge
dr. banner
you